最近很迷茫，
不知道要不要分开，
然后想咨询您一下啊，
我今年是28，
然后领证两年多，
办婚领一年多，
我跟我老公是高中时候在一起的，
然后大学以及工作这几年都是异地，
我目前是在一线城市工作，
收入大概是1.5W，
然后老公在三线城市，
收入大概是3000左右，
然后婚前他们家出首付，
我在她工作的城市买了一个房，
目前是他自己也还贷款，
然后每个月的公资基本都还贷款了，
我目前的存款有三十几个，
然后他没有存款，
有一些负债。
然后当时结婚的时候是男方家里一直催，
我不是特别想结婚，
主要的原因是一是觉得他不成熟，
然后不足以担负起一个家庭，
没有安全感，
第二是我也不想过早的步入婚姻，
因为当时才26岁，
我也不想去面对那些婆媳关系，
第三个是我们工作异地，
然后第4是我们也没有经济基础，
我觉得结婚生病啊，
生小孩啊什么都需要钱，
然后她当时也没什么钱，
而且总是向我借，
但是男友和她家里结婚的意愿就特别强烈，
一直催础，
所以当时我们就先领证了，
领完证之后就以为他家里不催了，
他还是一直催，
所以在领完证之后一年之后又办了婚礼。
当时结婚的事觉得我男朋友人品也没什么问题，
只是不成熟，
需要成长，
也可以结婚。
婚，
然后就办了婚礼，
然后我就一直在等他成长，
但是结婚之后发现也没有什么变化，
就我们经常会因为一些小事情吵架，
一吵架就冷战10天半个月，
而且我发现我们不说话的时候，
他对我的生活并没有什么影响，
而且他会偶尔会要向我要钱，
这一点我受不了，
就是因为结婚彩礼啊什么这一些问题，
他买房呀什么，
他借了一些钱，
他觉得这些钱我应该跟他一起还，
就是他觉得这些都是因为要娶我，
跟我结婚，
但我觉得这些无论跟谁结婚都会面临这样的问题，
就是我觉得你你现在求你可以去想办法去改变现状，
而不是向一个女人伸手要钱，
觉得这段婚姻没有给我带来任何意义，
但是他人品也没有什么问题，
也没有什么过错，
抽烟喝酒，
但是也不赌博，
第一是我不知道该不该分开，
第二是如果不分开的话，
我我不知道我该不该就是放弃我的工作，
然后就是回了他的城市，
因为他已经得达到工作的城市，
也付了首付买房了嘛，
目前就是现在我也不敢生，
结婚其实有证已经两年多，
大婚了一年多了，
但是我也不敢生小孩，
一直没要孩子，
因为我对目前的就是生活感到就是不没有安全感，
我觉得结婚之后有一些难题，
他就怕她处理不了，
然后我跟他提了一次离婚，
但是他坚决的不同意，
然后他他很。
爱我有什么他都可以改，
他希望一切我们能一起努力，
慢慢变好。
他当时给彩礼是给了多少钱，
加上订婚总共是17万，
然后就是包括三金啊什么的，
都在这些彩礼面，
那你现在手上的30万存款是不是包含了那个彩礼钱不包含，
这30万是我从两到之前和领证之后的，
所有的钱都在这一张卡里，
我当时也没有想过要分开，
所以也没有把这个钱存来，
这是我所有的积蓄，
就是婚前饭后都在一一张卡上，
那那个17万，
那个彩礼现在谁拿着呢？
就是17万的彩礼，
然后买3000，
已经买东西大概花了5万多，
剩下的12万在我父母了，
你俩这个收入差距真的是有点大，
你在一线城市一个月一万五，
然后他一个月3000，
这差距确实有点大了，
呃，
可能是因为就是一线城市，
他的工资收入水平就本来可能高，
然后他在三线城市，
就是那个当地的收活水平就市相对低一点，
你喜欢自己现在的工作吗？
你在一线城市工作的时候，
如果没有这个家庭的牵绊，
没有你现在这个老公给你情绪上的这个波动，
你自己工作状态好吗？
挺好的，
就是目前我这个工作还挺稳定的，
然后自己也比较喜欢，
那不要为了任何人放弃现在的工作机会，
你现在工作挺好的，
在那个经济。
环境不不好的状态下，
你一个月还能挣15000，
你这个状态很好，
千万不要任何人去丢掉这份工作，
如果说你觉得现在这个老公既不能给你经济上的帮衬，
也不能给你情绪上的价值，
他的存在只会让你情绪拉垮，
只会给你带来一些负面的东西的话，
那我个人觉得啊，
就是经济上别让人家吃太多的亏，
因为你们毕竟是没有孩子，
虽然说你们领证已经两年了，
但你们是分居的状态，
在这种情况下的话，
我认为彩礼还是该退一部分的啊，
是对，
如果是，
但是你要分开，
彩礼我觉得我是可以退的。
大概就是这么一个逻辑，
我首先是不同意你辞掉工作去到他所在的城市，
如果你掉一个月一万五的工作去到它所在的城市，
你找工作，
假设你可能只能找一个4000的，
5000的，
如果我想回家之后，
我就可能挣不了那么多钱，
然后我的生活质量首下会下降。
然后我也。
就是我，
他如果回家之后我生活过得不好，
我会把这一切都归咎于他，
然后我们有可能还是会走到分开那一步，
嗯，
啊，
但是他也没有什么过错，
嗯，
就是他只是就是不成熟不也不上进，
因为他现在工资比较少，
他说会做副业呀什么呀，
然后来改变生活，
但是我没有看到任何改变，
我之前觉得一切都会变好，
但是一切都没有什么改变，
我觉得看不到希望。
你要知道你现在的这个存款30万啊，
相当于婚前和婚后的存款混同了，
如果真的对方要提出要求要分的话，
你是可能要分人家15万的哟。
嗯，
早做规划吧，
我话只能点到这儿啊，
我最想问的就是我不知道该不该不太，
我跟我的父母讲了，
他们不愿意，
他们说这些都是小事儿，
也双方都没有什么过错，
然后不至于要尽力。
我认为一个男人不上进。
问你人要钱，
这个很致命的，
你就可能是因为他工作性质的原因，
就是那个工作也比较稳定，
就是收入也比较固定，
如果真的到那一步了的话啊，
你就不要说彩礼钱在你爸妈那里了，
你就说彩礼钱也在你这个30万存款里面，
那个时候假设啊要退他一部分彩礼了，
我们假设啊，
这个8万的彩礼的话，
那你就只剩下二十几万了，
那这二十几万的话，
对吧，
你给自己买点保险嘛，
买点那个什么医疗方面的保险啊什么的也很正常嘛，
是不是也没多少钱了，
就是我提过一次礼，
但是他不同意，
我应该就是怎么来说服他，
因为我觉得要些协议诉讼的话也比较麻烦，
告诉不了他不会同意的，
我要是个男的，
我一个月挣3000，
我找了个一个月挣1万五的，
呃，
老婆，
你觉得我会同意跟你离婚吗？
他说跟我在一起是因为就是很爱我，
就是喜欢我，
所以才跟我在一起。
但是我觉得我现在就是没有那么爱他，
我不我你，
我要不要继续，
我肯定不会同意跟你介意的，
你只能去打官司，
好的好，
嗯，
就这样啊，
好，
那好，
谢谢老师，
再见，
嗯，
拜拜。
我认为一个男的不上进，
问女人要钱这个事儿就是很致命的问题，
因为他不上进这个事儿，
他不会因为娶了你他就上进，
他不会因为你生了孩子他就上进，
他不会因为怎么怎么他就上进了。
啊，
不上进这个事儿是他从小就这样儿，
没错吧？